Traduttore: Peggy Berthier
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
La storia siamo noi, e dobbiamo farla.
Dobbiamo farla perché siamo
in una fase particolare,
siamo ad un bivio estremo.
Da un lato, abbiamo un futuro
che può essere drammatico;
dall'altro lato
abbiamo un futuro
che può regalarci
uno straordinario aumento
della qualità della vita.
Non c'è nulla in mezzo.
E chi ci obbliga
a questa scelta così estrema
è l'ambiente che ci circonda.
Noi pensiamo all'ambiente
– sappiamo tutti che è
in una situazione di degrado –
come se fosse qualcosa
che in fondo non ci riguarda.
Se perdiamo l’ambiente,
perderemo una bellezza,
ma non la nostra possibilità
di sopravvivere.
E ci dimentichiamo che noi
siamo parte dell'ecosistema.
Se l'ecosistema crolla,
crolliamo anche noi.
E una delle maniere
in cui ci sta già manifestando
che questo sta succedendo
è che ci spinge a degli inediti conflitti.
Adolf Hitler ha avuto
un ruolo preponderante
nella peggiore tragedia
della storia umana:
70 milioni di morti.
Solo che la sua vicenda
ci ha consentito di compiere
un salto in avanti
nella comprensione della differenza
fra la pace e la guerra.
Sì, perché fino ad Adolf Hitler
si pensava che la questione
era decisa soltanto
dall'elite, dagli apparati.
E mancava dall'equazione
un elemento fondamentale,
cioè la gente comune.
Solo che è successa una cosa strana:
Adolf Hitler non è arrivato
al potere con un colpo di Stato.
Ci ha provato nel 1923,
è stato messo in prigione,
ha scritto Mein Kampf [La mia battaglia],
in cui ha dichiarato
tutto quello che voleva fare.
Dieci anni dopo
è stato liberamente eletto,
anche se i suoi elettori
sapevano perfettamente
che cosa voleva fare.
E allora la domanda si è imposta:
"Cos'è successo?"
È successo che la gente comune conta.
La classe media tedesca,
cioè la porzione di popolazione
in assoluto più istruita al Mondo
fra le due guerre,
ha liberamente votato Adolf Hitler,
perché era sottoposta
a un pesantissimo stress socio-economico,
causato tra l'altro dalla crisi del 1929.
Ecco, prendiamo questo ragionamento
e proiettiamolo sul degrado ambientale,
in particolare sui cambiamenti climatici.
I cambiamenti climatici
sono l'aspetto del degrado ambientale
di cui si parla di più,
ma è essenziale capire
che non sono né da soli né isolati.
Questo schema,
che è diventato famoso
fra gli scienziati nel 2009,
vi mostra nuovi ambiti
in cui noi rischiamo di oltrepassare,
prelevando risorse,
le capacità di autorigenerazione
del Pianeta.
In alcuni settori,
che sono poi i triangoli rossi,
abbiamo oltrepassato di troppo
questa soglia di autorigenerazione
del Pianeta.
Il settore che si riferisce
ai cambiamenti climatici
è il triangolo che punta verso l'alto.
Situazione grave, ma non è la più grave:
ce ne sono altre due
che sono in condizioni molto peggiori.
Uno è troppo tecnico,
il ciclo dell'azoto;
ma l'altro lo comprendiamo bene,
è la perdita di biodiversità.
Ebbene, dobbiamo capire
che siamo entrati in un ciclo vizioso:
quanto più il clima si altera,
tanto più noi perdiamo biodiversità;
ma quanto più noi perdiamo biodiversità,
tanto più il clima si altera.
E allora, la prospettiva
a cui siamo di fronte è questa.
Questo è il grafico
della perdita delle specie
negli ultimi 200 anni.
Negli ultimi 50 ha assunto un'impennata:
i naturalisti parlano
di Grande Accelerazione,
oppure di Sesta Transizione Biotica.
“Transizione Biotica” è un parolone
per dire "Estinzione di Massa".
Siamo nella sesta Estinzione di Massa,
che si distingue dalle precedenti
per due ragioni:
la prima è che, con certezza,
la causa siamo noi;
la seconda è che non ce n'era
mai stata una così veloce.
Noi siamo abbastanza familiari
con l'ultimo episodio
di estinzione di massa:
quello dei dinosauri,
causato probabilmente da un asteroide.
Siamo abituati a vedere i documentari
in cui c'è un asteroide
che arriva, colpisce la Terra,
grande esplosione, onda d’urto,
e abbiamo l'impressione
che tutta la tragedia
si sia consumata in due minuti.
La tragedia c'è stata:
la perdita di otto specie su dieci.
Però è durata
da 30 a 100.000 anni.
Ecco, se si realizzano alcune prospettive,
alcuni scenari di cambiamento climatico
considerati realistici,
noi perderemo otto specie su dieci
entro la fine di questo secolo.
Solo che noi umani siamo meravigliosi:
invece di farlo in 100.000 anni
lo facciamo in 250,
da quando si è avviata
la Rivoluzione Industriale.
L'oggetto di questa esposizione è:
“Ma a me perché interessa?”
Perché mi interessa è spiegato,
molto meglio che da me o dagli scienziati,
da questo anonimo pittore
di murales londinese.
Ho l'onore di presentarvi il mio desktop.
Ogni giorno quando vado in ufficio
accendo il computer su questa immagine,
per ricordarmi per quale ragione lavoro.
Ce lo dice, [e] lo sappiamo tutti:
le api sono sotto pressione,
si stanno decimando.
Solo che le api non sono solo
una bella presenza da contemplare,
sono anche una funzione nell'ecosistema.
Ogni pezzo di questo straordinario
equilibrio, che chiamiamo ecosistema,
ha una sua funzione
di cui non possiamo fare a meno.
Le api impollinano.
Pensiamo a questi.
È difficile che noi
ci mobilitiamo per le api,
figuriamoci mobilitarsi per questo:
si chiama fitoplancton.
Eppure, il fitoplancton
è minacciato da un fenomeno
che gli scienziati chiamano
il "fratello dei cambiamenti climatici".
Anzi, lo chiamano il fratello malvagio,
dei cambiamenti climatici.
È l'acidificazione degli oceani.
L'effetto serra è causato
da un eccesso di anidride carbonica,
che iniettiamo nell'atmosfera.
Un terzo di questa anidride carbonica
è assorbita dagli oceani.
Lì diventa acido carbonico,
che rende difficile per il fitoplancton
produrre i propri scheletri.
Una funzione che si chiama
biocalcificazione.
Finora per il fitoplancton
è difficile riprodursi,
ma ci sarà una soglia fatale
in cui diventerà impossibile.
E succederà tutto d'un colpo.
Quando succede, il fitoplancton sparisce.
E la domanda è: "E a me?
Non ci vado mica a cena,
con il fitoplancton!"
Eppure, il fitoplancton è alla base
della catena alimentare marina.
Se sparisce il fitoplancton,
di conseguenza, in tempi molto rapidi,
sparisce la vita marina.
E ancora una volta: "E a me?"
Be', Il 12% dell'umanità
vive di prodotti del mare.
Il 17% delle proteine
che consumiamo vengono dal mare.
Ma sono ancora numeri che non fanno paura.
Il fatto è che la vita marina produce
il 55% dell'ossigeno che respiriamo.
Allora, questi fenomeni si producono
in questo campo improvvisamente.
Le cause si accumulano nell'ombra,
e poi le conseguenze
vengono fuori tutte assieme.
Teniamo conto di questo,
teniamo conto del nostro
ragionamento su Hitler
e vediamo questo scenario.
Vi mostro i ghiacciai
dell'Himalaya; si scioglieranno.
E non si scioglieranno gradualmente,
in proporzione all'aumento
della temperatura:
collasseranno, per un meccanismo
che sarebbe troppo lungo qui spiegare.
E la questione allora è: "Ma a me?"
Ah, la perdita della bellezza
del paesaggio alpino,
gli yak, la cultura tibetana...
Sono perdite straordinarie:
ma nulla, in confronto alla perdita
della funzione dei ghiacciai.
I ghiacciai hanno una funzione:
regolano il deflusso delle acque a valle.
In questa regione, se non ci fossero
i ghiacciai (è monsonica),
il clima sarebbe caratterizzato
da un'alternanza disastrosa
fra siccità e alluvioni.
Vengono improvvisamente meno i ghiacciai,
che in questa regione irrigano piane
dove sono stanziate
un miliardo e 400 milioni di persone.
Queste si trovano in una situazione simile
a quella della classe media tedesca.
Anzi, la classe media tedesca
ha compiuto le scelte che ha compiuto
perché ha perso il valore
dei suoi risparmi:
ed erano 40 milioni.
Questi perdono: acqua; riso;
strade; scuole; sanità -
Sono un miliardo e 400 milioni,
in un'area in cui quattro Stati
– Russia, Cina, India e Pakistan –
hanno la bomba atomica.
Houston, we have a problem!
Ma forse voi penserete che questo
è un delirio da politico, come sono io.
Lo pensano anche gli scienziati,
quelli che tengono
l’orologio dell'Apocalisse.
17 premi Nobel per la fisica,
che nel 2015 hanno posto le lancette
dell'orologio dell'Apocalisse
alla stessa distanza in cui erano
durante la crisi dei missili di Cuba,
cioè durante il peggior periodo
di tensione della Guerra Fredda.
Potrete pensare che questo
è uno scenario per il futuro,
ma purtroppo è uno scenario
per il presente.
Queste sono le zone
desertiche del Nord Africa.
Qui, delle popolazioni si sono abituate
a vivere compatibilmente col deserto.
Ma all'interno c'è una fascia,
una fascia attiva
dove non c'è il deserto,
c'è la desertificazione.
Visualizzatela e sovrapponetela
a queste dinamiche.
Qui è dove sono concentrati
i conflitti e la fame.
Qui è dove sono concentrate
le dinamiche terroristiche.
Qui è dove sono concentrati
tutti i traffici illeciti.
E qui è da dove vengono le migrazioni
che ci preoccupano così tanto.
C'è un'ovvia coincidenza;
spieghiamola in pratica.
Questo è il lago Ciad, al cuore del Sahel.
Ha sempre avuto una tendenza
storica alla variabilità.
Solo che, negli ultimi 50 anni,
si è ristretto di 18 volte.
Intorno al Lago Ciad
ci sono quattro Stati fragili.
Chiudete gli occhi e immaginate
se il Mediterraneo si restringesse
di 18 volte in 50 anni.
La nostra economia va in tilt.
Figuratevi l'economia
di quattro Stati fragili.
Allora non ci sorprendiamo,
se prolifera Boko Haram.
È in una situazione di stress
che nascono questo tipo di fenomeni
e che nascono anche le origini
di certi attentati che ci colpiscono.
E Boko Haram ha avuto il suo ruolo
nelle migrazioni che tanto ci preoccupano.
Bene, ma noi possiamo farcela,
possiamo fare la storia.
Basta la somma di piccole scelte
di sostenibilità di ognuno di noi
per risolvere questo dilemma.
E con qualcosa di paradossale.
Noi possiamo dire:
"La situazione è grave, quindi mi carico
del sacrificio di cambiare qualcosa."
No, quello che ci chiede la natura
non è un sacrificio;
è solo di vivere meglio.
Vi mostro due piramidi:
la prima è conosciutissima,
la “piramide alimentare”.
La troviamo anche
nelle riviste dal parrucchiere,
è quella che ci dice in che proporzione
dovremmo nutrirci di ciascun tipo di cibo.
Poca carne rossa,
via via fino a molte fibre, etc.
Se noi affianchiamo questa piramide
alla piramide dell'impatto sull'ambiente
della produzione
di ciascuna categoria di cibo,
coincidono perfettamente.
Ma nel senso che quanto più
un cibo è nocivo per noi,
tanto più la sua produzione
è nociva per l'ambiente.
Sembra una coincidenza; non lo è.
È il paradigma di come possiamo
rapportarci con l'ambiente.
Potremmo essere degli obesi
di trasporto meccanizzato individuale.
La cosa è la stessa.
Ma questa è solo la punta dell'iceberg.
Se noi tutti ci nutriamo,
non facendo un sacrificio,
ma come veramente ci consente
di stare bene, creiamo sostenibilità.
Ma non [è] solo sostenibilità:
creiamo anche una ridistribuzione
dell'accesso alle proteine
e consentiamo ai poveri di accedervi.
Ma se noi creiamo
anche questa forma di giustizia,
noi creiamo anche la pace,
perché in un mondo in cui ogni bambino
ha accesso a quella dose di proteine
che gli è necessaria per andare a scuola,
Boko Haram, le immigrazioni
e l’Isis non ci sono.
Vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)